as he bought bought a G wagon for his
Dalian D wife apparently d means oh is
£300,000 mAh and a G wagon so what bro
so what what's it got to do with you
Allah subhana T has given the right of
the Mah for the woman who are you bro
are you
jealous just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their m mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said the one who protects
what's between his lips and what is
between his legs I will give him good GL
Tidings of Jenna as an um as Muslims
I've been a Muslim for 11 years I have
never seen and I'll be honest with you
I've had this testimony from Brothers
like Muslim
B in the comment section and wherever it
may be us Muslims and and I I think for
me to generalize I think I'm not going
to put every single Muslim in this
category but we are one of the most
toxic people when it comes in the
comment section W just imagine do you
know how many people are going to enter
the fire because of the stuff that they
say now it's come to light that Subhan
Allah these rumors I'm just shocked like
Zan contacted me and said bro you know
you you want to do a video about chunks
Etc and I thought well what's there to
talk about you know he got married may
Allah bless him Etc and he's like no you
don't understand I you should do some
research and I was thinking I mean what
could possibly be said about chunks he
got married may Allah bless and protect
his marriage may Allah Grant him
righteous children and inshallah that
his marriage marriage lasts
forever and when I looked into this
matter I was shocked
I mean my wife even sent me some stuff
and I was like is this is this for real
like people are now trying to number one
first is a Manhunt about who his wife is
are you guys possessed are you tapped
like well I don't know if this is coming
from the sisters cuz sister can be a bit
nosy you know who his wife who who did
he marry oh my gosh look at her they
just want say you know oh look look at
her lashes oh look at her nose oh he
could have done this you know sisters
like to talk Subhan Allah yeah or is it
the brothers you know who have come with
absolute slander and in Surah if you go
to the Quran inah Allah
talks about those who slander chunks I
met his dad in couple of years ago in
Brent Cross aldah he came across like
came to me and he said you know youve
done a video about Mas and I was like oh
my gosh is it one of the reputation
videos that I done you know am I in
trouble and you know SP in my head and
he was and I didn't know who he who he
was Subhan Allah and he's like trunks I
was like oh chunks I was like yeah yeah
cuz I was thinking in my head I've done
nothing but spoken good of him alhamd
he's not infallible for that matter and
I've advised him once in private and wah
he's somebody that takes advice he took
the advice and took down I'm not saying
because of my comment but the point is
alhamd I spoke to his dad you know
alhamd he told me stuff about his son
alhamd everyone will talk good about
their child but I genuinely believe the
chunks brother our brother trunks
alhamdulillah has goodness in him
alhamdulillah he's someone who's
memorized the Quran his wedding was um
segregated alhamdulillah yes there are
shortcomings he had and he knows that
and I'm sure he doesn't justify and say
it's it's Halal the issue is not even
that now the issue is pertaining to the
honor of his wife and himself first
thing the people are talking about what
oh it's £300,000 Mah and a G wagon so
what bro so what what's it got to do
with you Allah subhana T has given the
right of the M for the woman who are you
bro are you jealous are you jealous
what's your problem bro if she asked 10
10 million pounds it is at her
discretion okay I mean if chunks can
afford it which I'm sure he can what's
your problem bro why you butt hurt huh
why you why you so why does it bother
you this is there's two types of
jealousy and envy there is one that is
not blameworthy you're not sinful and
the second one you are the first thing
is that you see something in some some
else want it for yourself make Dua for
it number two is something that you want
it to be taken away from them I'm going
to read you guys some comments it's
shocking Subhan Allah let me tell you
something if you have a problem with
somebody's blessings your problem is not
with that person it's with the one
that's giv them them blessings and who
who is it who H the billionaire
millionaire the industry no it is Allah
subhana wa tala if you have a beef like
Shan had a beef with Adam and he got
doomed forever in Hellfire why because
his beef wasn't with Adam it was the one
who gave what Allah gave him that which
was Allah subhana tala so anytime you
have envy and jealousy the one that's
blameworthy your beef is with Allah bro
or my sister okay for the sisters who
were out there jealous Etc you know
whatever maybe or for the brothers out
there who are jealous because you don't
have what he has or whatever for that
matter what is your
problem you will never attain anything
what are you going to do bro what are
you going to do fight him he Allah's
blessed him with it you only you're only
going to eat your self up alive W one
thing that a principle that you have in
your life is what wanting good for
others always want good for others
jealousy will do nothing but consume you
and Eat You Alive like Adam alam's
children one murdered the other one like
Shan fell into disbelief it will even
lead to if you carry on like this Subhan
Allah and all I want to say to chunks is
may Allah subh bro this a fine reminder
this the reason why alhamdulillah my
wife didn't even want to speak on a
video alhamdulillah with she there's
nothing wrong with speaking it's Haram
she did not want to speak because these
people are tapped in the head bro this
me to you chunks protect your wife
protect yourself and your wife cuz me
and my wife when out on about I tell my
wife to wear now she's not but I tell
her to wear when she's out about with me
why because since tried to take a little
fly slide pictures you know how many
times I had to stop my wife from boxing
up some sisters because they tried to do
some Sly ones you know trying to take
picture of my wife okay how many times I
had to stop my wife from boxing up some
sisters yeah I'm not saying like
literally but she was going to go in a
mad one because man I'm out with my wife
why did you why you so flipping nosy man
wah he the nosiness and a lot of the
times it comes from the S I'm not going
to lie they're just so damn nosy who is
it oh my gosh what kind of oh my gosh he
married that race oh my gosh look
brother man what's your what's your
problem man mind your own business man
mind your own business so my dear
brother chunks you and your wife please
do your number two when you're in public
bro be very careful I would even highly
recommend you I would advise you to tell
your wife to wear in a car I personally
advise bro trust me bro now that this is
going on Aki they are going to try to
find a picture they're obsessed they're
tapped in the head Subhan Allah look at
some of this disgusting things that is
going being said W I do not even want to
repeat it this of some dirt scumbag may
Allah subhana T give all his Good Deeds
to you and your wife Yeah bhak Boy
chunks allegedly couldn't couldn't have
couldn't couldn't have gotten himself a
n10 aristocratic beautiful Adan princess
Adan means you know a white person
princess from Kensington but allegedly
decided to settle down with a two out of
10 Balian mocking Somali yeah Balian
Merchant from the streets of Minnesota
huge L who are you brao man who the hell
are you and Subhan Allah look look look
may Allah deal with men who look look at
this Subhan Allah look this is something
so vile I don't even want to
speak they are questioning
her they are questioning her Chastity
man these things can destroy households
how would you want to be a part of
destroying a household imagine let's
suppose cuz this is an outright blatant
lie imagine a separate brother a
separate brother who is married to his
married to his wife and his wife had a
past she had a past something that
bothers every man she had a past but
false rumors just false it's not true
somebody just decided to make up
something and say ah I bet she slept
around or I know she slept around arum
and it's a full outl he's lying he's
lying but now that man knows that
reality with his wife he knows and he
has said Allah has forgiven you and
whatever it is it's it's hard for every
man but he's let that go and said you
know what he's fighting his demons and
he's going ahead with a marriage how do
you think you're going to make that man
feel when you are spreading Lies when
that man is acknowledged and it's a sin
that's happened whatever it is for that
matter and then now youve left that man
paranoid cuz he's thinking why why did
he say that so does he know something
what are you going to get out of it
Subhan Allah what are you going to get
out of it that's why was revealed to
defend against slander Subhan Allah look
at this yeah and they sharing these
pictur of some woman basically apparent
that's not even her yeah some non hijabi
sister Etc saying that's not even her
video CH spent £300 as Mah as he bought
bought a G wagon for his Dalian D wife
apparently d
means and they got married in Minnesota
look at this look at look at this
unbelievable W unbelievable look at the
stuff that they're saying look at this
people are so jealous of him and expose
his identity how prophetic this exactly
true yeah look wow chunks is a man that
literally had the past of having
girlfriends being in sexual relation
relationships and everything he has done
and continues to do do is of complete
sin how dare they try to downt talk his
wife no matter what the woman has done
how are you even talking about this like
it's facts look at this look what dumb
comment you're mentioning as if it's a
reality it's all slander and then you
are there yeah it's unbelievable you're
trying to defend his wife on by saying
oh yeah but if his wife done then he's
also done it where's your evidence man
Allah says in the Quran Allah says in
the Quran and I'll end on this Allah
subhana wa tal
says and those who accuse honorable
chased women with false charges they do
they do not bring four
Witnesses if they do not bring four
Witnesses so flock them with 80 lashes
and never accept the testimony after
that and indeed they are the disobedient
transgressors this is why Allah subhana
tal has established lashing in public
and to never take that person's
testimony again because this destroys
households this destroys people's honor
and a woman's honor we know that's why
Islam is so severe and we know the
prophet Muhammad said seven sins yes he
mentions
about um adultery if I'm not mistaken
and one of the last ones is what to
accuse a chase woman of her subh her
Chastity Subhan Allah and Allah subh
says to what it says don't worry and
this is an Ayah I will say this is for
our Dear honorable sister chun's wife
subh Allah subh says and do not think
this is bad for you rather it's good for
you know why my sister
on all of those lies and slander that
was made against your husband and you my
dear sister on you are going to get all
of their good deeds and check this out
if they run out of Good Deeds guess what
they are going to carry you and your
husband's sins the sins that you have
now it's going to be like now you're
carrying sins because you've run out of
look at it you've run out of the good
good deeds now you're going to carry
their sins and I make it and I make Dua
that Allah subhana wa tala makes it a
means to purify our chunks and his Dear
honorable wife who's our sister and we
will defend their honor till the death
of us because the Sharia calls for us to
defend this honor so when some people
come and say Oh Brother Ali you guys
love jumping on everything how can we
not jump on something like this when it
comes to enjoying good and forid and
evil yes the prophet said you either
enjoying good and forbid evil or that
even if you prostrate in Salah it will
be rejected from you okay even if you
when you make supplication it will
rejected from you Allah will send that
Calamity something along those lines
Subhan Allah yeah why because this is
why many nations before went astray why
because they just let it be we're not
this is a serious matter that has to be
dealt with I want to say Subhan Allah
that for us to be careful with what
comes out our mouth many people are
going to end up in the Hellfire man it's
not worth it keep your business to
yourself jealousy do your my brothers
and sisters W jealousy and envy is a
real thing I'm telling you w I believe
even in that wedding there's people who
just they just don't like it they're
they smiling but deep inside they're
burning they don't like it the fact that
you know why the junk chunks marry him
yes okay or brother brother it's like
that W that's what Allah has told us Sal
protects
you it protects you against magic evil
eye this is H bro chunks you cannot go a
single day without doing have car with
your wife and protect your wife at any
cost inshah I personally would advise at
this rate trust me um that your wife
wears a just to protect I do the same
thing with my wife bro if my wife is on
the kab that's all I want to say in
sorry if I got a bit agitated but it's w
it really really hurts me that people
are going down to this level to insult a
man on his day that he has to take down
his to man may Allah deal with you guys
you oppresses that's all I'm going to
say inah may Allah bless and preserve
you guys and keep us inah on the